n'est ce pas qu'il est beau c'est quoi
comme chien un boxer mélange avec un
berger belge
oh là là là là ça doit se marier ces
bêtes là bas est normalement les deux
parents 20 pedigree il n'aurait pas dû
se marier
non non les en empêcher c'était la
famille angleterre voilà et ça fait ça
fait ça ça fait neuf ans que je l'ait
pas que un peu ses deux lancers de
l'arthrose avant c'est comme nous quand
on a des rhumatismes un oui mais je
donne des cachets je vais pas encore
donné je lui donnais tout à l'heure
ouais ouais vous faites quoi vous ben je
promenais mon chien je vais rentrer à la
maison tout simplement mais si vous
voulez venir prendre un verre
pourquoi paraissent pas dans la vie vous
fait quoi
un show sur man a dit des choses oui en
discothèque avant mais oui ok le disque
dans toutes les discothèques de france
ça s'appelle qui est devenue l'enjeu
bleus
tu as mal à la papa tu prouves db
eh bien on rentre bien dans ton amara
tu en as marre ton avis si bédié
c'est un peu comme quoi ici non c'est
pas trop bien fréquentée avant il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de problèmes de
drogue mais apparemment ça l'air de
s'arranger
bien qu'elle avait drogué beaucoup de
revendeurs mais la police il ya mis son
lay ça va beaucoup mieux
sans ça oui on est bien il vendait quoi
même des l'héroïne du shit fin ils ont
des taux tout et rien enfin bon avec le
chien m'embête pas comment il s'appelle
the sun qui bus info rentrée la saline
alors que je te retire la lèze bébé à
temps rires je crois que j'ai coupé la
télé non attends allez maintenant le
divan sommes allés à coucy son livre
whif à cesser sa place alors on m'a dit
que vous aviez parlé dans ce domaine
belles photos de sévices
c'est votre jean-jack queyranne qu'elle
vient stallone un ouais mais ça c'est
qui c'est mon fils alors en quoi il
était dense est finie la gamme en trois
ans et va réveiller ça y est on n'avait
pas travaillé d'affaires mais bon ça va
bonsoir on attend ils peuvent avec la
salle où il a trouvé la parade
le siège est peut être là le wesh weezy
licence avec les fauteuils tech la façon
dont la chambre cheikh salah hamza mais
je crois que tirer les pailles que toi
oui dans mais non il est un beau
portrait de stallone et les fous de dieu
ni d'ailleurs avant que vous arriviez on
a écouté 2h02 à l'écouté quoi les
concerts de johnny que j'éprouve
magnétoscope away son concert de des 50
ans au parc des princes fait voir mais
l'inde ou chez vous un tueur à main sont
en train d'enregistrer la victoire aux
points
c'est mon pote mois tantôt n'a pas le
chemin de la victoire en quoi tu attends
là je le faire parce que qu'est ce que
tu vas faire là qui sait où se situe le
geste et le bouddha les devises qui l'a
presque vide avance avant tirs j'avais à
ces bouteilles sont pas absentes en
regardant regard dont jalila oui mais
c'est quoi comme risqués s'est opéré
c'est pas une marque connue ce une
marque s'attaque à la fois leclerc mais
bon il est bon ça ça me paraît oui ça
saoule bien c'est du stade puisqu'ils
away
j'espérais qu'il serait assez souple
d'ordures et de laisser tranquille mais
manque de pot aux roses il aurait
travaillé comme une portée de s'ouvrir
1 c'est pas grave mais sympa jean louis
est très gentil les jaloux un peu j'ai
passé six ans à bord ouais mais non mais
bon ça me dit on est jaloux de ce qu'on
aime bien sûr que c'est ce que je fais
parce que je suis il est déjà venu avec
moi j'aime pas trop mais enfin pour
l'argent il est bien obligé de me
laisser faire
et alors bah il est venu à la
discothèque qui s'est bien amusé il a
participé à cinq quand tu la vois sur
scène ça te fait quoi quand as-tu fait
elle fait des strip tease en seconde
opale dans les segments la salle est
fermée sérieux se bat ça lui fait
plaisir d'un côté ça le salarié qui
claude quoi qui fait attention à ce que
les mecs n'approche pas trop mal mais
facile de défendre tout seul sans jamais
un coup de symptômes alors toute façon
c'est pas grave
non mais je sais je le fais tous les
combats avaient chaud sur seine aube
beaucoup moins maintenant un coût moins
quinze ans d'enregistrer six heures
parce que c'est jamais moi qui demande
aux discothèques qui m'appelle oui il ya
un salon des discothèques deux fois dans
l'année j'y vais je ne fais pas je fasse
mes coordonnées puis on met lass est
régulièrement il te fais des films pour
nous mais j'avais dit que les âges en
effet avant d'être avec lui j'ai arrêté
de plus qui fait avec le non cinq ou six
et tous les pièges veut plus en faire
parce qu'ils veulent par ce protégé met
pas de préservatif avec le sida moi je
suis pas me dire fait décidemment il est
jeune donc si je suis avec lui je sais
qu'il a rien j'ai rien fait dix ans que
je fais ça une époque de ma vie pour
élever mes enfants mais maintenant j'ai
plus besoin de ça
les enfants étant élevé jamais de la
grande histoire d'amour c'est quand même
temps vous êtes ensemble 6
je puis vous êtes connue comme la fête
de la musique dallière dans un café un
mammouth et lunettes de soleil carnaval
aux yeux j'ai connu il serait tombé 1
donc c'est connu dans un cadre et
c'était la fête de la musique ouais
et puis bon puis voilà et puis son frère
est un de mes meilleurs amis de tous et
tous savaient qu'ils avaient à faire
personnellement je n'aime pas vraiment
horrible il passé si j'avais d'autant
qu'on est là c'est vous êtes final on se
dispute enfin se chamaillent comme tous
les couples
ils veulent adultes des glaciers si
j'étais pas fidèles ils vont vous aurez
aussi sur le fait que c'est avec lui
j'ai pas fait un pas à côté puis j'en ai
pas envie d'allaiter du canton ainsi na
waie alors il a toujours la pression que
dans le métier que je fais puisque je
suis aussi comédienne en plus des
discothèques dans ce métier là on trompe
facilement mais c'est pas vrai du tout
que c'est pas vrai du tout non mais
laissez moi
[Musique]
quatre salles n'étaient qu'à six
barrettes tu devrais pas mal d'aller
chercher un whisky car enfin whisky
ouais bah oui bah oui grâce les vertes
mais c'est bien beau mais si je fus tu
vois tu peux tu as où vous avez déjà
bien l'arroser la soirée est adoptée pas
quoi sixième question sinon jamais oui
dix mois
c'est une bonne semaine le dernier que
j'ai fait je me suis fait avoir c'était
j'ai tourné dans les visiteurs ils ont
tourné les visiteuses et j'ai tombé
dedans a préféré visiter mais j'avais un
rôle comique à 1
j'avais un rôle kouassem qu'est ce qu'un
bon menton dans ce genre de film ça ça
marche bien j'en ai un peu forte
ça m'aurait bien toi et moi j'en veux
bien ou ce match 4-2 mais ça marche mais
ça marche bien mais bon moi je n'attends
que ça content d'enfin savoir bien oui
gaza lui aa
il semble exister ce qu'ils savent que
j'ai fait les visiteurs clavier
normalement les visiteuses succès 2-1
2-3 une petite dose une petite dose je
crois qu'il n'en a pas moins de 80 n'a
plus un double up store battant moi je
vais avec avec du coca comme ça j'ai
juste trentenaire mois moi je veux bien
peu de coke avec chéri commettre se
gagne pour un show dans une discothèque
c'était tranquille 500 francs pas je
demande c'est ce que l'ajax sa
essentielle à narita ils voient les
fiches de paye toutes les fiches de paye
quand même bagis montre sa main le
problème des discothèques maintenant
c'est qu'elles veulent plus nous
déclarer ouais donc je peux pas faire
une discothèque
je pars en attendant c'est toujours
mieux que de bordeaux ne veut plus dans
mes côtés si j'en fais mais je veux pas
faire des quotas qui me déclare temps et
après avoir dézingué avec les impôts
ouais parce que en ce moment ils sont
durs avec les gens du spectacle et des
élèves les jeunes militants voir ici le
pays
mais c'est pas mal parce qu'il pourrait
vous faire dire s'ils travaillent cela
me ramener beaucoup d'argent et fait
plutôt le contraire
alors que beaucoup de gars sa place à
pas agi comme ça on connaît maintenant
il a du fond jean jacques faut bien
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu